mit dem neuen Wahlrecht könnte die CSU
aus dem Bundestag fliegen und Markus
Söder tut schon voller Angst durch
bayerische Kinos
nein nicht Scream 6 hier
Götterdämmerung in Bayern das
Unvorstellbare könnte Realität werden
Fassungslosigkeit und Entsetzen machen
sich breit auch auf den Straßen Bayreuth
haben sie schon von der Wahlrechtsreform
gehört ja die CSU gibt es vielleicht
bald nicht mehr im Bundestag ja ist
schon gut
kann man nur sagen
gute Arbeit ja sauber
kommen sie aus Bayern
zum neuen Wahlrecht habe ich nur eine
Frage nimmt es der Söder persönlich ich
bin wieder da ja kurz Zeit danke wie
geht's dir gut die Ampel hat heute das
Wahlrecht geändert und ich habe mir
extra aufgeschrieben was ich dazu sagen
wollte oh nein super laut kurze fix die
CSU konnte bald aus dem Bundestag
fliegen das wäre ja super schlimm also
für die heute-show wird es ein Dessert
da muss man dazu sagen ja
gemeinsame Verfassungsbeschwerde
vorbereitet
aus Comedy Gesichtspunkten muss die CSU
dem Bundestag erhalten bleiben es fehlt
nur noch ihre Unterschrift ja das ist
meine das machen sie weil das passt
schon ich möchte unbedingt dass die
heute schon weiter sich gegen ZDF
Magazin Royal durchsetzt und es geht nur
mit der Zinsen
ein Autogramme Verfassungsbeschwerden
okay
dann haben wir keine CSU mehr in Berlin
ja dann müssen wir halt dann am Stock
auf Berlin machen das mal kriegen ich
würde sagen geh mal als Bayern nach
Berlin dann würde das alles erledigt es
ist schon ein Meisterstück
so verhalten wie wir uns aufregen würden
wenn der zwei Oppositionsparteien oder
so versucht rauszukicken gleichzeitig
hat die CSU ja jetzt Jahre lang auch
jede Form von Wahlrechtsreform
verhindert das stimmt doch nicht wir
haben Vorschläge gemacht das Problem ist
nur
so profitieren wir sind ein großer Fan
von der Stärkung der Direktmandate
wissen als eigene Partei gibt das weiß
ich wirklich nicht
[Musik]
die Veranstaltung läuft jetzt ja was
1848 die Paulskirche war ist 2023 das
Cineplex in Bayreuth merken Sie sich das
hier findet historisches statt es geht
um nicht weniger als die Abspaltung
Bayerns schade eigentlich denn was hat
dieser Mann nicht schon alles für sein
Land getan das habe ich gemacht habe
Minigolf Turniere organisiert
was weiß ich alles ich bin die Friseurin
Mike gegangen ich war bin 18 alle
Kneipen gegangen ja und habe ob die
Leute das wollten oder nichts hat mir
das bitte wählen Markus höher super also
da haben sie jetzt schon unterschrieben
unseren gemeinsamen Antrag
ja wir wollen doch gemeinsam Klagen in
Karlsruhe dass die CSU aus Comedy
Gesichtspunkten den Bundestag Gehalt
bleiben ist ich dachte ihr wollte eine
klar gemacht dass der die Zwangsgebühren
abgeschafft werden die Zwangsgebühren
und das nicht wo kommen sie doch jetzt
nicht runter oder ziemlich coolen Spruch
ja dann wünsche ich Ihnen dass ihr den
nächsten Freitag Abend auf jeden Fall
bisschen schöner werden als mit Markus
oder im Kino das war sehr nett
auch eine Form von Verdrängung und damit
zurück
ich glaube nicht dass das hier gerade
noch jemand sieht Wetten lieber heute
show Fans wenn ihr das hier noch seht
schreibt in die Kommentare gerne
tasknecht schauspielerische Darbietung
hat mich zu Tränen gerührt und abonniert
gerne den Kanal danke
und die endcard macht ihr jetzt hinter
jedes Video klar auch wenn ich nicht
darin vorkomme